[Music]
they say family is what you make it
and more often these days making that
family means going online surfing the
web to find your future baby daddy or
Mama seeing some great guys that kind of
fit your criteria from searching for
sperm it's kind of like a very extensive
online dating profile to choosing a
platonic co-parent you know you want
someone more involved you want someone
to help carry the load it's a new era of
Family Planning income education level
one that's appealing to a growing number
of prospective parents like Tiffany
Soper
had you always wanted to be a mother I
wanted to have a family and I knew that
perhaps that traditional family unit
wasn't going to be my reality and so I
started to kind of prepare for that
knowing that I wanted to have a baby
regardless of the situation while in her
30s and busy with her own PR firm in
Vancouver Tiffany started to plan ahead
with the help of Dr Sonia kashup
director of Genesis fertility biology is
something that doesn't wait for us and
we don't have a lot of control over you
know I've had serious relationships but
I was never the right person at the
right time to be like yes let's do this
let's start a family Tiffany froze her
eggs a process that's become
instrumental in closing with Dr kashup
calls the fertility gender gap so men
make new sperm every two to three months
so throughout their life
they can reproduce for women we don't
make new eggs we're actually born with a
finite number of eggs that we will
deplete in quantity and quality as we
age after age 35 or 37 the quality of
those eggs also diminishes Mother Nature
is just not caught up with us yet over
the course of the pandemic fertility
clinics and sperm banks saw demand for
their services increase as much as 20
percent we certainly saw an uptick in
couples individuals same-sex couples
being interested in starting their
families in women freezing their eggs if
you have to visit like a counselor and
have a session that's when Tiffany felt
the time was right four years after
freezing her eggs she was ready to start
her family was it the pandemic that
I mean I think it definitely gave me
that opportunity to really stop
reevaluate everything I realized that I
was working too much and that I didn't
have to live my life that way anymore
and that I could fit in time for a baby
in time for family if I if I wanted to
if I made the decision to do that she
was 42 at the time
and the options were to use insemination
where we watched sperm and put it in the
uterus or to decide to thaw and
fertilize her frozen eggs right and so
she decided to go with insemination and
to keep which is not uncommon to keep
her frozen eggs for later
perhaps in case she met somebody that
she'd like to have children with later
that's your uterus although eggs age the
uterus is capable of carrying babies
even past menopause and this will be our
leftover here after choosing the method
it was time for the final decision
sperm so I went through an online portal
a firm donation Clinic based in the U.S
in Canada it's prohibited to compensate
egg donors or sperm donors we can
purchase firm from sperm banks which
mostly come from the U.S I've spent
several months researching donors it was
a really really hard decision to make
what were you looking for I was just
looking for like a donor that stood out
for me where I was like okay like it was
more just like a feeling rather than
specifics like obviously there was
certain physical attributes and you know
clean medical history and you can look
at personality tests you can look at
education career and yeah I was just
looking for a donor that just felt right
it took months but she found one once I
saw the donor that I wanted to pick I
kind of made the decision really quickly
Tiffany's donor was Anonymous but some
women want their sperm to come with a
degree of Parental involvement haul
would be nice I'm a tall woman 5A
without heels with heels like five
eleven like Stephanie reibel a 42 year
old single woman working in sales and
living in Los Angeles
to a guy who already has a child that's
divorced and wants another one yes I
would
um I would be open to people younger
that have never had a child yes and you
would be open to a gay man that's like a
single professional 100 Stephanie sought
out the help of Yvonne farovich the
founder of the website Mo damelie um you
know it's a lot like regular dating but
for a different purpose it's basically a
dating site for people who want to be
parents we connect people who are ready
to have kids and start a family whether
you're looking for a romantic
relationship or a platonic co-parent or
a known sperm donor we have one of the
largest databases in the world of
co-parents and donors and people just
looking to start a family or help you
start your family Stephanie is bisexual
and has two children who were carried by
her former partner I've dated all ages
like my age older younger lately younger
now she wants to give birth to a child
of her own but doesn't want to do it
alone ideally I would like a romantic
relationship and a partner that's ready
to have a kid but I like that this site
can give me an option for a platonic
relationship which kind of takes the
pressure off so if I do want to find
somebody down the road like at least
then I've had my children and I have a
great co-parent and then they can come
into my life in a romantic way and they
can still be involved with modemily men
have the option to go beyond being just
sperm donors we have one of the largest
known sperm donor databases where
there's men all over the world that are
open to being a known donor as opposed
to an anonymous donor and those donors
can choose how much involvement they
want in the child's life it could be
anything from occasional Hangouts to
full-time co-parenting there's a lot of
men in their 40s or 50s that maybe spent
a lot of time in the single scene and
not settling down and they're getting to
a point where they want to have children
or maybe they had a child and they were
married and divorced and they want
another child but they don't want to get
married again but damily users can look
for someone on their own but Stephanie
chose to use the concierge service where
Yvonne walks clients through the steps
to make the pregnancy happen I
personally work with you to find either
a romantic co-parent or a platonic
co-parent or a known sperm donor and
I'll verify their identities and I could
help facilitate you know health checks
and psych evaluations and develop legal
agreements whether it's co-parenting
agreement or a known donor agreement so
we're basically like an advocate for the
client work like a Matchmaker except for
trying to help you find you know a
co-parent or donor as opposed to
traditionally a boyfriend or girlfriend
and while sperm banks struggled to
attract donors from various ethnic
backgrounds modemily says for them
that's not a problem so we do help
people find those harder to find donors
whether you're looking for an
African-American donor or an Asian donor
or a Jewish donor even if it's not on my
database I have ways to like reach out
to other places I help the woman find a
Harvard educated donor so I I advertised
in the you know Harvard Crimson
newspaper paper and just did Facebook
campaigns and Instagram searches so you
know we use a variety of methods to find
donors if we don't have them within our
own database Stephanie is excited to
find her match I mean if I could do it
by the end of the year love it that
would be ideal
Tiffany's insemination was a success she
got pregnant on the first try and is now
the mother of a baby girl named Birdie
it was like the most profound experience
of my life I'm really grateful to have
gone through that even just the
pregnancy and everything and the birth
was like
such a phenomenal experience made
possible because of an anonymous sperm
donor who birdie may meet one day our
donor has what's called open identity
disclosure and that was important to me
because I wanted birdie to have the
option if that's something that she
wanted
after she turns 18 she can connect with
him through the sperm bank and provide
his contact information and he's open to
that
[Music]
have you thought about what you're going
to tell birdie as she gets older and
asks questions about her parentage and
or her father
I have yes so as soon as she's old
enough to sort of understand or just
start to talk about it you know
messaging like we have a unique family I
needed a little bit of help to get here
but I just really wanted you so badly
I definitely want to be open and honest
about it
[Music]